I accidentally found the most mind blowing
endgame theory on the Japanese Internet.
Also you guys forced me to sing Bink’s sake
on Camera to celebrate one HUNDRED thousand
subscribers.
All of this and more in this video.
What’s up everybody.
Ohara here and today is a good day.
Because I have, not just one, but TWO real
goodies for you today.
And I personally definitely know which one
I’m more excited about.
Nope not that part.
You’ll get to witness me questioning my
life choices in real time if you make ‘till
the end of this video.
The bad news for me is: You will, because
it’s a damn good video.
I’ll summarise how we got here as quickly
as possible, so we can get to the juicy bits.
Let’s put 30 seconds on the clock:
We reached 100K subs.
I asked you guys to come up with a video idea
to celebrate
You guys picked singing Binks Sake over Eating
Bread.
Then I thought to myself: Hm.
Instead of torturing you guys right from the
start why not talk a bit about the song itself
a bit.
I think there might be a thing or two in there
that might be interesting.
So I looked it up.
And what I stumbled upon blew my fucking mind.
Was that 30 seconds?
Damn.
Okay let’s cut to the chase.
The premise of this theory is from a Japanese
One Piece fan who goes by the name Chipiko,
mixed with my own ideas and other random stuff
I found on the interweb.
That guy.
Went through the original Japanese lyrics
of the song and gave his interpretation for
each important line.
Without giving too much of the mind-blow that
I definitely had away, the basic idea is that
this song talks about the final island of
the grand line.
Laugh Tale.
Wait!
Before you click away already, let me also
spoil the last line of the song.
In the English translation it goes ‘Never-Ending,
Ever-wandering, Our funny Traveling tale!’
That already sounds a bit like Laugh tale.
But in the Japanese ORIGINAL it’s actually
even more in your face.
The word Oda used, Waraibanashi, literally
means a laugh tale.
Literally.
Like, that’s so straight-forward, that it
actually makes me wonder whether Oda didn’t
just put this into 2003 Google translate and
got Laugh Tale as a result and just went with
it.
After all Oda put a ridiculous amount of thought
into this and had the song ready many years
before we actually reached Thriller Bark,
while the island itself is first mentioned
as far back as chapter 105.
I hope that convinces you that this song is
not only a good chance to humiliate a poor
YouTuber, but also carries a deeper meaning
hinting at the climax of the story.
Let’s start with the very first line of
the song.
Let’s go and deliver Bink’s sake.
This already brings up 2 important questions.
Who the bleep is Binks?
And what the bleep is his sake?
Well according to Chipiko, as the song is
pretty old, Binks is someone who’s already
dead.
Top candidates is whoever wrote the song.
Joy Boy, the D Clan, the Kozuki or all of
them.
Since sake has pretty strong symbolism in
Japan and is often associated with one’s
life’s story, Binks’ sake might actually
be delivering his story.
This story, so the theory, is the true story
of the world, engraved in the Poneglyphs.
There are 4 road Poneglyph leading to Laugh
tale, but more interesting are the 9 historical
ones, that contain the lost history.
According to this, delivering Bink’s sake
means nothing but finding all 9 historical
Poneglyphs, stringing them together and bringing
the full story with you to Laugh Tale.
And speaking of Robin, when Brook plays the
song, Robin mentions that she has heard it
somewhere before.
On a pirate ship she traveled on maybe?
Only the word she uses in Japanese is natsukashii,
an adjective that can’t be translated literally
but expresses for memories of a time past.
I think the only time Robin has genuinely
warm memories of is her time with the scholars.
And if the heard the song in connection with
the research of Poneglyphs and the ancient
Kingdoms, wouldn’t that make perfect sense?
The second interesting part of the first verse
is this.
The birds sing as they draw circles in the
sky!
Circles?
Birds?
Yup.
This might very well be a reference to the
Kozuki themselves, the creators of the Poneglyphs.
The bird in front of a circle that might very
well depict the sun as well as 4 arms, that
remind us of the classical Jolly Roger.
Keep that in mind.
We’ll get back to this in a second.
The last interesting line from the first verse
is this.
Tsumugi no sato yo.
Tsumugi no sato is the village of spinning.
The village where what was spun?
Well, why not the story that is engraved in
the Poneglyphs.
This would mean that the village talked about
in this old song would be no other place than
Wano itself, where we are right now.
The place where the Poneglyphs were crafted
going all the way back to the void century.
Are you warmed up already?
Good, let’s go to verse 2, cause we’re
just getting started.
After introducing the Binks, the Kozuki and
their story in the first verse, the second
one seems to describe some of that history
we just talked about.
We start with this: Warera kaizoku, umi watteku.
This is translated as as ‘We are pirates
sailing through the Sea!’
This is however too liberal.
Watteku doesn’t mean sail, but to cut or
to divide.
Thus the line actually says, we are pirates,
parting the sea.
Now, yes, this could just mean cutting through
the waves with the ship, but what if this
was way more literal?
Remember the Kozuki crest?
What if the pirates did indeed cut the sea,
let’s say in 4 pieces using a giant continent
and a dangerous current.
And could the X be the literal location of
laugh Tale?
The backside of reverse mountain, that technically
IS the end of the grand line.
The song continues: Now comes a storm through
the far-off sky.
It seems that this seems to be a reference
to war.
The storm brewing being a metaphor for conflict.
Thus, this line might tell us about a war
in the past or in the future, related to the
island.
The verse then ends with If you lose your
nerve this breath could be your last.
But if you just hold on, The morning sun will
rise.
This seems to refer to the dangers associated
with Laugh tale.
It tells us that people have failed before
and died trying.
But even though people failed, th morning
sun will rise.
The morning sun, in other words the dawn.
Thus, the person who will bring the dawn will
one day appear after many others have failed.
This my dear viewers is nothing else but the
theme of inherited will.
And speaking of leading themes in the story,
the third verse starts talking about the dreams
of today and tomorrow.
Once again this is inherited will and passing
on dreams to another.
In this case it specifically means the dream
of those who originally wrote that song.
It continues: Te o furu kage nimo mou aenai
yo.
Once again the English translation misses
out here The line literally translates not
to Waving our goodbyes, we’ll never meet
again, but to this: even though I will never
meet the waving shadow.
This seems to refer to someone living in the
present.
Only the living can cast shadows.
And so it directly addresses the one who has
inherited their dream in that moment in time.
But don't look so down, For tomorrow night
the moon will also rise!
Ah the moon.
I actually made an entire video about its
meaning and connection to the past some time
ago.
If you’re interested I’ll link that for
you up here.
Apart from its heavy symbolism, what it actually
reminds me off is ‘Your Name’.
In case you haven’t seen the movie.
Watch it.
It’s fantastic.
But if you don’t want to get spoiled skip
20 seconds ahead.
In the story, at dusk when the moon comes
up, it’s possible for two worlds to touch.
So that might already be a hint that laugh
tale is only accessible during a certain time
period at dusk and again at dawn.
The song ends with this: Doesn't matter who
you are, Someday you'll just be bones.
Never-Ending, Ever-wandering, Our funny Traveling
tale!
What this line says is that everyone will
have to die some day and the song ends by
literally name-dropping laugh tale.
The never ending, ever-wandering island.
So what’s the big payoff here?
Hold thight.
Laugh Tale is the land of the dead.
This is where people go in One Piece.
How do we know?
Brook.
Thanks to his fruit, he was able to return
from the land of the dead.
He is the one that first plays the song.
The first crew member Luffy wants is a musician.
Brook introduces us to the concept of Souls
and soul power.
His clash with Big Mom is all about the soul.
But wait.
There’s more.
Remember Rayleigh saying that they were to
early when they reached Laugh tale?
Well, the simple answer to this might be:
They weren’t dead yet.
Roger also told his first mate that he would
never die and gladly handed himself in to
be executed.
The D. Don’t fear death and greet it with
a smile.
They are connected to the land of the dead.
And is it really a coincidence that they were
singing the song on Roger’s ship when they
traveled to Laugh tale in chapter 967?
And I want you to take a look at this recent
panel here of Yasuie at his execution.
The last thing he says is this: I will now
make my way to the other world.
Let’s sing all together.
Why would you sing when you are about to die?
Was Yasuie about to sing Bink’s sake?
In other words: Is it possible that Laugh
Tale is actually so difficult to reach, because
it means entering the realm of the dead?
An island that only appears at dusk and that
you already have one chance
of enter